now Scotland's first Minister Hamza
Youssef has told Sky News that things
have to change in his party as a scandal
engulfs the SNP he was speaking on his
way into the Scottish Parliament for his
first prime minister's questions well
for first Minister's questions in
Hollywood he's done one before a
Scotland correspondent Connor Gillis is
in Edinburgh for us and Connor what did
he have to tell you because he's now not
just first Ministries Finance Minister
for the SNP as well
yeah he is treasurer of the SMP and was
attacked during that fiery exchange yet
again here at the Scottish parliament in
Edinburgh by those opposition
politicians saying that he is a first
Minister compromised he is an SMP leader
who has bogged down in Scandal and is
paralyzed in terms of moving the country
forward accusations that of course comes
the use of very firmly denies but let's
make no mistake about this he is in deep
crisis the party is in deep crisis
yesterday the treasurer of the SMP Colin
Beatty resigned after of course earlier
on this week being arrested question
detained by detectives for most of the
day and then released without charge
pending further inquiries following
high-level talks with the first Minister
and the SNP leader at Colton Beatty took
that decision to resign from that post
well what happens then well Homer Yusuf
has another job to add to his plate he
is now an acting charge of the snp's
finances as Treasurer while the party
looks to track down a replacement for
Colin Beatty let's bring you a few words
to put the first Minister had to say in
a huddle with us as journalists in the
last few minutes
Douglas Ross asked and are you facing
bankruptcy as he suggested we're
definitely not facing bankruptcy I'm
pleased to say that we are in a steady
footing when it comes to party's
finances I don't think Parliament is the
place to do a statement on the party's
finances but I've of course instructed a
governance and transparency review I
mean the report comes in on that review
I'll make that public he also was going
to ask if you're still owe money to
Peter Morrow I think there is money
still absolutely outstanding to be
tomorrow in terms of the repayment of
the loan how much again it would be
important that I leave that out after
the governance and transparency review I
don't think I need to lay out give a
running commentary in the snp's finances
line by line but let's let's look at the
governance and transparency review do
its work is that a sign of which is
in the coming days and it's a sign of
witness
again I will need to look into that
matter I'll link to that issue but we do
have a party lawyer that is there to
represent staff at Columbia's situation
is slightly different of course uh his
issue is that he's a was a national uh
office Spirit until he chose to step
back so I don't think maybe so far
we don't have an auditor yet so we're
still making progress still in
conversations with a number of Auditors
is that a sign of weakness you didn't
sat column BT yesterday Colin BT and I
came to a mutual agreement and he agreed
to step back he understood he understood
how difficult it would be for him to
continue in that role so there's no need
for me to sack on be he did the right
thing because he always has the interest
of the party
so there we have it Hamza Yusuf saying
the SMP finances are in good shape from
the man who yesterday was thrust into
the position of having to deal with the
treasure rule as well discussion In that
clip there as well around Auditors let's
remember the SMP has been without
Auditors since September last year there
is a looming Financial deadline when it
comes to its accounts it has to submit
fully independently audited accounts by
July to the Electoral commission and
that deadline is looming very very fast
let's hear what some of the other
opposition politicians said in the
chamber a short while ago including Anna
sarwar from Scottish labor
on Tuesday Yusuf tried to convince the
country that he represented a fresh
start 16 years of command and control
financial mismanagement and a complete
lack of transparency this isn't just how
they governed their party it's how they
govern the country
Peter model the former chief executive
of the SMP who was also arrested
released without charge a number of
weeks ago he has been spotted outside
the home that he shares with his wife
Nicholas sturgeon this morning the first
time since that arrest a reminder that
this live police investigation continues
Connor Thank you very much